[Music]
there are so many Eagles here bald
eagles are our national burden for most
people in the u.s. there are rare and
magnificent sighting but for us it's
just part of our daily lives everybody
in town has an eagle Suri
[Music]
I'm Carlin and Lowe born and raised in
Alaska and I am the Unalaska Visitors
Bureau executive director even though
our island is almost 80 miles long there
are nearly 600 birds in just a few
square miles
which is crazy there's an unnatural
amount of birds here because we
contribute to their food source these
bald eagles are so amazing and we love
seeing them but when they're involved in
your daily life they can make running
errands or your work really difficult
you read something as simple as mailing
a letter can be dangerous I'm officer
would with the an Alaska Department of
Public Safety our department put up
these signs to one the community about
the dangers of the nesting Eagles which
are right next to the post office Eagles
have been known to swoop down and attack
people they're very territorial and
they're just trying to protect their
nests the eagle's nest is right there
and here is the post office some people
have been hurt during these incidents
but I've also heard some funny stories
I'm Pam Oz and I run bingo here at the
Senior Center every other Sunday I was
carrying this box it had something like
bingo stuff in it all of a sudden a wing
hit my head the talons came down grabbed
the box and flew down the street and I
never saw my bingo box again but if you
want to see a whole lot of eagles you go
to the landfill I'm Steve bastok I work
at the city of Onalaska the landfill
one of my favorite places to be also one
of the Eagles favorite places to be I
know that Eagles are scavengers and
predators so they like trash to they'll
pick up whatever they think might be
food my name is Bob Wilson I've been
fishing out of the Bering Sea and Dutch
Harbor for 40 years Dutch Harbor is one
of the largest fishing ports in the
world every time we pull in we know the
Eagles are waiting for us so they can
steal our fish as we offload it do I
think they're pests oh absolutely but
they're cool pests so that's okay they
make a mess of my boat which is kind of
the bad part but they are national bird
and we love them anyway how's that
[Music]
Oh Kenosha Irma Island is a short 12
minute ferry ride from her Oshima region
of Japan while the sandy and palm-lined
beaches are perfect for holiday makers
the island draws crowds for a different
reason
rabbits lots of oh and how they got
there is a mystery between 1929 1945 the
Japanese army secretly produced over
6,000 tons of poison gas on Okinawa
Island
some believe the current rabbits are
descendants of those brought to the
island to test the gas but the current
director of the poison gas museum
insists these bunnies have nothing to do
with those from the world war ii era so
where did they come from
saggy kimono saggy you don't necessarily
need you know more one theory a cocoon
in science redecorate a noir think you
can imagine any demo today Khadijah so
for the Catena
sake kinda could add uno momento de
artists money mata Mata colinearity
muscle so those rabbits were released
and with no real predators they bred
like well like rabbits and yet another
theory Americanize acabas de voto de la
concorde not opening was a youkai
hajimeta
sorry buddy mono okinawa de have some
creatively the can coca call your
Havarti muscle so yoga very nice name
either way this new generation of feral
rabbits has a run of the land they're
creating a new story separate from the
sordid past of Okinawa Island an island
once known for death is now known for
possibly the cutest thing ever
bunnies
[Music]
Chimp Haven is a retirement facility
this is their forever home this is where
they come to explore and and live like
chimpanzees in June 2013 the director of
the National Institutes of Health made
an announcement that virtually all of
the chimpanzees would be retired from
research we have close to 200
chimpanzees here now around half of our
colony are veterans of research that was
focused on a cure for hiv/aids as well
as hepatitis C and so as a result of
that those chimpanzees had to be
infected with those viruses good morning
Gina
genetically I'd say we're about 98%
identical to a chimpanzee and as you can
imagine that's why they were ideal
subjects and test studies because they
want to learn more about how they can
benefit humans so I would definitely say
that the human chimp relationship is one
that is ever-evolving give me their hand
give me good girl they're a lot like us
in our family dynamics
you see siblings they're interacting
they're playing with one another every
relationship is different it's just like
that's with humans
certain individuals you'll have really
close intimate relationships with some
not so much we also have seen some
behavioral changes where chimp as he
might appear to be overly timid and you
know see a change in that over time we
might see that chimpanzee is a lot more
interested in exploring the five and
half acre habitats and this might have
been the first opportunity that they had
to do that
I think it's such a great benefit to
know that this is where they'll live out
the rest of their lives and to know that
despite whatever their past may be we
are at least giving them the opportunity
to live out a time of retirement where
they're with other chimps where they're
able to exhibit these species typical
behaviors and they're just able to be
chimps and know that you know what life
is good
[Music]
go here the sanctuary we have our own
motto that we believe in and it's saving
one animal may not change the world but
surely for that one animal of the world
will change forever and we fully believe
that because we see it every day my name
is Pat Craig I'm the executive director
and founder of the Wild Animal Sanctuary
located in keansburg Colorado
this x-ray was started 36 years ago I
visited a zoo one time so I was really
surprised to see all these lions and
tigers in the back kept in tiny little
cages and I found out they were surplus
and that they actually euthanized those
animals so I opened the first sanctuary
in the country for large carnivores oh
so in the beginning I started on the
family farm right outside of Boulder
Colorado at the time you know I dropped
out of school and started working
full-time to support the animals and
build more space and go get more animals
we started to get phone calls from law
enforcement agencies who are finding
apartments in basements about 85% of all
the animals here were legal
confiscations from people who either
abused them or had them illegally and
the rest either come from zoos circuses
or other places like that that didn't
have them
we have over 420 rescued carnivores
living here and everything from wolves
tigers bears lions leopards mountain
lions you name it I mean there's a lot
of mouths to feed
we feed over 38,000 pounds of food a
week these animals are absolutely like
my kids just because this is my life
turned into a seven day a week 365 day a
year job that I've been doing for 36
years and you know there is no time to
go anywhere for vacations or anything
else it's all for the animals wasn't
something I expected to do and it would
had no idea how monumental I was going
to get but it's been worth it every bit
of the time so I wouldn't it wouldn't
have changed at all
[Music]
one core trait in every dog is its ever
forgiving nature that's probably the
most valuable thing in a dog and it's
also its biggest pitfall because we have
dogs here who've been horribly hurt by
human beings and yet all they wanted was
find somebody else to look around the
world strays mutts and street dogs are
victims of stigma in Costa Rica Leah
battle is trying to change that story
she runs the territory oh dae-su Qantas
it's a lush haven for stray dogs to
either be adopted or to live out the
rest of their days the reptilians are
what this stands for
land of the month my name is Leah
battles better known as crazy dog lady I
guess I started 30 30s I got this
partly because I've always loved animals
all animals but it wasn't in my plans it
wasn't like I set out to do this the
need for this I think all over the world
is because there's a huge stigma around
a dog that doesn't have a breed they'll
let mutts wander on the streets or
they'll actually toss them on the
streets because they're not breed dogs
the solution isn't euthanizing a dog
the solution is make sure it's not born
in the first place once it's here do
something good for it
find a home or if not at least offer him
a place where he can be in peace and
happy keeping territorial up and running
is no easy feat they eat $500 a day in
food alone Leah has to work a full-time
job to keep all the dogs fed and healthy
parrot audio stays about partly through
miracles I think keeping this afloat is
a huge task it's a labor of love
you can't pay someone to care for an
animal truly to remember their names to
be gentle to them while this place is a
dog heaven
nothing beats getting adopted by a
loving family I'd say it's like kids at
kindergarten they love their friends at
school but oh they all want to go home
to mom and dad
you
[Music]